welcome to this video playing Grand
Master Krupa this job dear john young
man he has the job flick maybe working
there as a coach on check I don't know
really ok he took on c3 without being
provoked which is quite rare but it's a
playable line it's just not not fully
yeah yeah it's not one hundred percent
correct line but still playable of
course it leads to very close positions
we are white enjoys them quite a
substantial advantage in space
yes I'm trying to grab as much space as
possible
yeah white has this big space advantage
on the Kings side so it's not advisable
to Castle them and team he didn't castle
just put the King on the other side of
the board it's of course not easy at all
provide to to do anything against the
King on a eight but I don't necessarily
need to play for direct attack got this
nice advantage in space yeah this is an
interesting way to play maybe you can
play f 62 to open up the position but
then I what I don't want to do is fall
too far behind all the clock this can
can easily happen here as you consider
various ideas you forget how much time
you actually have left yeah yeah I can
take play night e to and win the spawn
yeah I guess so take stakes he has no
way to protect their form I can even
play rogue age 40 and 8 app takes takes
rook age 49 f for the problem is this
night on the aid which is just a very
bad piece um if I take now takes here on
on g5 now go g6 County interesting maybe
I just take means is also good structure
the the g file controlled by this wide
rook
ok so how to make headway probably
doubling on the G file group g5 ruji one
he maybe wants to learn I 2h7 taking the
h4 palm that's possible I go look g5 his
plane i th seven as well
hmm
I get the Queen over ok
no general okay once you get my to you
five of this limb that's a bit of a bit
of an unlucky unlucky is the wrong word
bit of an unfortunate piece of placement
yeah I simply forgot that this was
saying to be honest yeah well this is
I've played really really badly Wow yeah
at the beginning of this I was in
excellent shape but then I completely
miss plated like completely idiotic
Queen III yeah this is this is not
simply quite resigned yeah I completely
lost the thread and I think that that
this is simply good for what I mean very
very good for white from ya come compass
on are also giving me a large edge but
this doesn't help i need to be precise
and i didn't i didn't play precisely
taking all you have six is probably the
first bad move the main point why i
think that white is better is the bat
night only eight it bites on d6 and
cannot go to f6 and I take okay because
i think that the g file is still giving
me an edge but I allowed Bishop c8 and
has simply forgot that you can take the
night on 25 and he I need to be more
precise you know look you wanna stuck on
move with a very big edge yeah it's it's
it's pretty clear that white should have
something I wasn't sure about f5 to be
honest with the computer is just
unimpressed and why does winning
according to to the
silicon friend yeah I was I was
irritated about this and this is why I
took and here here I need to improve I
mean here probably it is still still a
playable position but I simply failed to
recognize the basic idea and ninety
seven witches really embarrassing
because what else is the IDM and here
I'm already in big trouble very
difficult to to keep a playable position
I know I'm just toast yeah this was bad
I completely spoiled it around here I
think that that the whole black setup is
simply are simply bad I mean it's just
passive and he's got no snow space
whatsoever so he should have some some
problems but the real problem is neither
for which I think it's just in
combination with f6 is just a mistake he
needs to to stay maybe retreat to g6 or
something but this leads to two very
good play but it's very complicated and
i played this just badly bishop CA 1097
is very good very good they're here i'm
toast i have no way to defend I mean age
for they've got too many weaknesses here
h 4f 3 C 4 and all this wouldn't have
happened in the in the other line where
you keep keep control over the position
alright thanks for watching